your one of your first roles you did
like all my children right
like you I know you don't talk about
that a lot but like I always find these
soap operas people go oh it's a soap
opera but the amount of dialogue these
folks have to learn and oh it was
terrifying I I could I couldn't do it
when I say that I really I could not do
that I would I would explode how did you
what were your what was your preparation
like trying to do something like that
well I was very very nervous I think my
first time
on All My Children
I played a couple of different
characters on that a few years apart my
first time I played a Canadian mountie
and Erica Kane for those of you who are
familiar with Susan Lucci's character
for a thousand years on that show
was was stranded on cobbler's Island
somewhere in the great white North and I
was a Canadian Maori not like you know
uh
Nelson Eddie uh not wearing the the red
outfit but you know in the office and uh
and I did my first episode learn my
lines and and you know she had more
lines than I did so so it was just a
question of not screwing up and uh you
know hitting your mark and and just
trying to be there and trying not to
hyperventilate and you know all the
experience doing theater all those years
and having those opening night Jitters
uh helped I think prepare me for that
um
the writing of course is not exactly you
know Shakespeare or Arthur Miller but
um but I you know I felt like I I
pulled it off I acquitted myself okay I
didn't soil my pants I I I didn't you
know fall off my chair and and it was
fine and then and then I was called back
I was living with my aunt and uncle at
the time off and on between uh their
house in Westchester where my five
cousins grew up or you know couch
surfing in Hell's Kitchen and um and my
my recurring line in my three or four
episodes that I ended up doing was
we can't get out to cobbler's Island to
rescue Erica Kane because it's fogged in
so I must have said 13 different times
did you tell them about the fog
and and of course my brilliant actor
brain realized after I had done my first
episode when I went back to do my second
oh wait I'm Canadian eh so I need to say
did you tell him about the fog
and smoke so this character that I was
playing between the first episode and
the second episode which were probably a
few episodes apart you know in the grand
scheme uh I'm guessing some of the Die
Hard All My Children fans kind of
wondered wait a minute is this guy it's
the same guy right why does he sound
like a completely different human
knowing you you probably did really a
lot of research with that uh with that
diet yeah yeah yeah yeah of course we
didn't have computers at the time so
I was at the library reading about the
RCMP yeah